vamos al problema 110 problemas 110 dice
lo siguiente cada que martín paga una
cuenta en un restaurante de entre 10 y
99 pesos 1099 entre estos valores el
calcula la propina como dos veces el
dígito de las decenas ok entonces por
ejemplo si si pagó 32 de cuenta entonces
la propina que deja es 62 veces 3 si
pagó 71 de cuenta la propina que deja es
14 va luego lo que nos pregunta es lo
siguiente martín acaba de pagar una
cuenta de entre 10 y 99 o sea estamos en
este caso la propina que dio fue mayor
que el 15% de la cuenta entonces
queremos saber si la propina
la propina fue mayor al 15 por ciento de
la cuenta bueno vamos a ver qué
información tenemos en el inciso 1 nos
dicen que el total estuvo entre 15 y 50
entonces 15 es menor o igual que el
total que es menor o igual
que 50 bueno lo que queremos saber es si
la propina fue mayor que 15% o más bien
si esta información es suficiente para
determinar si la propina fue mayor que
15% o no para ver que esta información
no es suficiente lo que tendríamos que
hacer es ver que hay ocasiones que
cumplen esto y en las cuales la propina
a veces es mayor y a veces es menor a
15% vamos a ver qué sucede con algunos
valores que sucede por ejemplo si la
cuenta fue de 40 si la fue si la cuenta
fue de 40 lo que se deja de propina es 8
vale y cuánto es 8 de 48 de 40 es igual
a 1 entre 5 que es igual a 20 por ciento
entonces en este caso que está en este
intervalo tenemos que que la propina si
le gana a 15% y qué sucede con otros
valores no sé qué sucede si la cuenta
fue no sé digamos de 16 pues en este
caso lo que se deja de propina es dos
veces uno es decir dos y cuánto es dos
de 16
de 16 bueno pues 2 de 16 es lo mismo que
1 entre 8 y esto en porcentajes después
sería 100 entre 250 entre 225 y otra vez
entre 2 para llegar a entre 8 que sería
12.5 12.5 por ciento y entonces en este
caso la propina es menor que 15% y así
saber que la cuenta quedó aquí no nos
permite determinar si la propina es
mayor que 15% o no porque a veces si lo
es y a veces no lo es entonces esta
información por sí misma no es
suficiente vamos a ver qué dice el
inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos dice que la
propina que se dejó fue de 8 entonces la
propina
la propina fue de 8 esto lo que nos dice
es que la cuenta fue de 40 y algo verdad
de 40 x digamos entonces la cuenta fue
digamos 40 41 42 o cualquiera de los
valores desde 40 hasta 49 48
49 vamos a ver si en este conjunto de
valores si sucede que la propina siempre
es mayor que 15% que sucede por ejemplo
aquí en 40 en 40 en 40 la propina que se
deja es de 8
ahí ya hicimos esta cuenta por acá
verdad que nos quedaba que la propina es
del 20% lo cual si le gana 15 a 15% y
que sucede más pacas de hecho hacia acá
es el caso feo verdad porque estamos
dejando una misma propina para una
cuenta más grande entonces qué sucede en
este extremo pues en este y en este
extremo de acá también dejamos 8 verdad
de 49 dejamos 8 y cuánto es eso en
porcentaje pues sería 8 entre 49 y esto
será mayor que 15 por ciento pues a ver
déjame hacer este truco 8 entre 49 es
mayor que 8 entre 50 porque aquí estamos
dividiendo entre un número más grande y
8 entre 50 es lo mismo es lo mismo que
16 % 16 %
verás y 8 entre 50 es lo mismo que 8
entre 100 entre 2 el 2 sube y nos queda
16 entre 116 entre 100 y por lo tanto es
16 % vale bueno entonces en este caso
dejamos 16 % que si le gana a 15 por
ciento y en los otros también verdad
porque estamos pagando una cuenta más
pequeña y entonces estamos dejando
porcentajes de propina más altos
entonces la información del inciso 2 si
es suficiente para determinar que se
deja más de 15% de propina entonces la
respuesta sería b
vamos ahora al problema 111
el problema 111 lo voy a hacer en
naranja y un poco más abajo porque el
problema 111 el problema 111 dice lo
siguiente el precio por acción de x
incremento 10% en el mismo periodo que
el precio por acción de que disminuyó
10% esto suena muy emocionante
luego nos preguntan el precio reducido
de y qué porcentaje es del precio
original de x ok vamos a hacer esto con
calma vamos a ponerle que tenemos una
acción equis y tenemos una acción y les
voy a poner así barritas para
distinguirlas de sus precios vale y al
principio está esta acción x tiene un
precio x esta acción ya tiene un precio
y nos dicen que en un cierto período de
tiempo x aumentó 10 por ciento es decir
x se convirtió
1.1 x y ya disminuyó en 10 por ciento es
decir ya que se convirtió en 0.9 y sale
esto de aquí es al inicio del periodo y
estoy acá está el final del periodo muy
bien y lo que nos preguntan es lo
siguiente nos preguntan el precio
reducido de che qué porcentaje es del
precio original de equis o sea lo que
queremos saber es básicamente cuando es
0.9 y 0.9 que el precio reducido de iu
dividido entre el precio original de
equis o sea queremos determinar 0.9
entre x y para esto es suficiente
determinar cuánto es y entre x vale
entonces bastaría determinar y entre x
ahora si vamos a ver qué opciones
tenemos en el inciso 1 lo que nos dicen
es lo siguiente que el precio
incrementado de x es igual al precio
original de y el precio incrementado de
x
punto 1 x es igual al precio original de
y es igual al de aquí podemos determinar
el valor de entre x pues si es muy fácil
simplemente dividimos entre x a ambos
lados de esta igualdad y nos queda que
1.1 es igual a entre x y por lo tanto
este numerito que buscamos 0.9 y entre x
es igual es igual a 0.9 x por 1.1 1.1
muy bien ahora veamos qué sucede con el
inciso 2 con el inciso 2 en el inciso 2
nos preguntan o más bien nos dan de
información que el incremento en el
precio de x fue 10 11 ambas partes de lo
que disminuye oye a ver el incremento en
el precio de x es 0.1 por x
y nos dicen que eso fue 10 11 ambas
partes
10 11 ambas partes de lo que disminuye
hoy y lo que disminuyó 0.1 y sale
dividiendo entre ambos lados entre 0.1
tenemos que x es igual a 10 entre 11 x y
entonces ahora dividiendo entre x entre
x entre x y multiplicando por 11 entre
10 por 11 entre 10 por 11 entre 10
tenemos que estar se cancelan tenemos
que 10 se cancela con 10 11 con 11 y por
lo tanto tenemos que 11 entre 10
es igual a g / x que básicamente es esto
mismo de acá porque 11 entre 10 es 1.1
entonces cualquiera de los dos incisos
nos permite determinar el valor de entre
x y con ese valor de entre x podemos
determinar lo que nos preguntan y esto
que nos preguntaban era el valor
reducido de g entre el valor original de
x vale bueno nos pedían un porcentaje
pero ya con esta fracción simplemente
multiplicamos por 100 le ponemos 1 % y
ya quedó vale bueno vamos a dejarle
hasta aquí y continuamos en el siguiente
vídeo